[Música]
gottardo todos
é curioso que nas apresentações todas
que ouvimos
eu vim a ouvimos viagens ouvindo
história houve um desconhecimento houve
uma escultura ouvimos emoção ea única
coisa que eu consigo pensar em mim
o vinho na relargada aconteceu na minha
vida muito chato tive o privilégio de
ser exposta a produção de investir muito
pequenina e como é comum na maioria de
nós portugueses
o vin faz parte do nosso dna faz parte
da nossa cultura e muitos nós fechamos
ou com um avô com algum familiar a
produzir vinho nem que fosse em casa nem
que fosse para consumo próprio
minha história não é muito de frente
ativa só tentam do texto muito pequenina
vieram meu avô pisar o advogado granito
e desde essa altura ficou eu consegui
fazer uma quase uma fotografia na minha
rotina das penas de atendidas de vinho e
creio que esse primeiro memória olfativa
que tem o cheiro a fermentação é claro
pegar
talvez seja demasiado romântico pensar
que o meu percurso
efe o início aí mas agora que olha para
trás e faz de tudo que fiz ao longo da
minha carreira
percebo que os canalhas que estão
interligadas pessoas que eu gostava de
fazer a partir das histórias que de
alguma forma traduzem o meu percurso ea
visão ou se quiserem chamar missão do
como eu quero contribuir para o
conhecimento de português no mundo ea
primeira história então sobre
resiliência ambição e conhecimento e não
imagina a quantidade de vezes que salve
a mina trabalham em vinho
mas a mim não tem nada tem de beber
vinho banheiro não preciso ter um
alcoólico para ser um pouco profissional
e ser profissional é exatamente aqui o
ponto crítico para o setor trim é
preciso ter um conhecimento sólido um
conhecimento que está em uma base
científica porque vem tanta emoção como
tem deficiência expor um lado a emoção
para o consumidor para um profissional e
meio está na minha deficiência e às
vezes temos a sorte de aliados e isso é
uma emoção
eu não digo que o conhecimento tenha que
ser só científico mas essa ciência faz
com uma marca tenha cuidado consciente e
eis que critique próximos dias é
produzir vinhos concordado consistentes
porque isso leva a lealdade dos
consumidores
eu não estou a dizer que os índios têm
que ser todos iguais não tem que ser
como coca cola mas sim tem que haver
essa base consistente para nós podemos
comunicar a nossa marca
eu vinha de facto um produto muito muito
complexo com muitas variáveis na
produção e da higiene está o
conhecimento científico da informação
engenharia alimentar e e no último ano
da faculdade tive a minha experiência
internacional foi processo está fazendo
estágio e depois de de voltar a
trabalhar na produção dar aulas na
universidade passavam os anos e
antiética não sabia fazer e que mesmo
toda a exposição ao setor e e ao mundo
um extremamente profissional nos estados
unidos não foram suficientes e também cá
não foi o suficiente para realmente
saber fazer e para isso e pensar neste
momento agora é aprender e aprender tem
que aprender com os melhores do mundo e
é uma coisa que durante
o curso isso é uma coisa muito pessoal
minha
é sempre procura inspiração em pessoas
que mostram o que poderão provas nas
suas áreas ou pelos valores ou pelo grau
de conhecimento ou porque é o porteiro
incapaz é a capacidade de mudar o curso
da história e do conhecimento
são pessoas que têm sempre objetivos
maiores si próprios e no segmento de
sempre estar expostas sempre procurando
inspiração destas pessoas
um dia a candidata tem anexava
califórnia em davis que tem o melhor
programa programa prosa poder pode
negociar os vinhos do mundo
e para surpresa minha filha site via
site
entre os oito únicos candidatos que
foram selecionados naquela estudo na
realidade até parece demasiado ambiciosa
mas o que eu queria na realidade era ter
um diploma se assinado por uma estrela
valioso que não é para enfrentar estes
foram de facto os anos os melhores anos
da minha vida
para usar os tucanos pra mim mesmo em
atingir todos os objetivos que me propôs
a estudar e trabalhar e dormir rápido
muitos dias muitas vezes e fui
assistente dos grandes para os óscar em
os dedos são referência no setor de
vinhos e que o mundo inteiro estuda
conseguir também concluir hutu o
programa em tempo record
tive esse privilégio e ao mesmo tempo
assumir a responsabilidade que um dia
tinha 13 para buscar esse conhecimento
mas o conhecimento de uma forma que toda
a gente entender se eu lembro me
inclusive um dia estar a ponderar uma
vinha e pensar no que eu estou aqui a
fazer na califórnia puder chardonnay
pinot noir com nós temos em portugal
tanto de óptico e especial e que é
preciso fazer alguma coisa por isso
existe potencial em portugal para
produzir vinhos com o meu chama se essa
paz fins que não se conseguem produzirem
mais conhecidos no mundo
e esses são os tais vinhos que momento o
ritmo cardíaco e mesmo precisando de
ciência consegue causar em um céu então
uma visita ao porto férias já com
emprego em sonoma surgiu a oportunidade
de abrir o primeiro hotel vínico de luxo
em portugal
o direito não é um hotel aqui no coração
do distrito do porto e ficai ficar e
porque se a gente precisava assumir o
compromisso de ser a primeira diretora
vinhos de portugal
isto numa altura em que a maioria dos
produtores via como concorrente o
vizinho do lado e não via concluindo
espanha frança e itália
fiquei porque queria participar nessa
mudança e deixei para trás o meu micro e
mark 82 deixei a casa ele a sheikha
deixei todas as minhas coisas e você
voltar passavam animai para recolher
tudo e aqui começa a segunda história
uma história sobre criar pontes e
desmistificar o vinho que na realidade é
pergunta e resposta à pergunta que mais
não fazem mas o que faz uma diretora de
vinhos cria pontos e de justificar o fim
se perguntarem ao meu filho e eu disse
como já aconteceu na escola
a minha mãe trabalha no hotel em breve
no dia inteiro que não é verdade e eu
provo mas não devo isso fora do contexto
pode levar a mais importações prova do
fato muitos vinhos em 18 anos de
carreira provavelmente foi mais de 50
mil vinhos própria porque esse é a única
forma para lembrar no sensor o nariz é a
única forma de conhecer e reconhecer o
perfil sensorial por cada um dos
produtores e porque tem um conhecimento
científico tem a capacidade e quando
prova perceber exatamente o que combinou
fez quando introduziu vim sem nunca
sequer temos falar
então o que faço é construir pontes
fazer pontos entre quem produz o vinho
entre quem consome e aqui o que é
crítico que quer fazer
desmistificar o fim e descomplicada e
tem opção na califórnia que sempre dizia
quando preparava para dar as aulas
práticas em querer assistencial beatriz
quem sabe simplifica quem não sabe
complica que o setor vive já tem em mim
essas coisas complicadas é tão
complicado que não se consegue perceber
as cascas do vinho as regiões
a linguagem técnica e um idioma quase
que ninguém consegue entender enquanto
os dias e que já ouvi uma frase que eu
gosto mesmo de mim mas não percebo nada
percebem sabems koston isso não gostam e
exposta às vezes não é preciso discar o
tenor uma fruta ou maiôs ouro uma
bergamota é só preciso provar vem exerce
gosta os nossos costa porque nós
complicamos tanto que entrei na altura
as 85 m dadas por escolher um vinho e o
que acontece
houve uma cerveja sem ofensa ao setor da
silversea mas eu tenho que defender os
meus em três e é isso que não pode
acontecer
então eu queria partilhar hoje é uma
ferramenta que criei e que muito orgulho
é uma grande honra estar das linhas do
vietnã que chama o enxoval do anjo não é
um cartãozinho editado em modo de vista
trata toda a dinâmica vinhos que faz o
objeto no hotel veículos
começando com as parcerias com os
produtores nacionais de norte a sul do
país e das ilhas
a seleção da loja a situação da garrafa
era a quantidade do jantar vínico e foi
com esse luiz
todas as masterclass todos os eventos
consumidores acham certo ano partes o
criciúma só a espécie tudo que fazemos a
cerca de vinhos noite em que o torna o
hotel vínico de luxo e aceitar tem de
estar organizada por regiões ou por um
estilo de vinho tab é organizado por
personalidades por personalidades ou
características que todos nós
conseguimos relacionar pode ser um vinho
ícone pode ser um famoso pode ser uma
nova tendência ea descrição que é feita
nunca é feita de uma forma sensorial é
uma linguagem para o consumidor nunca
fala que o vinho tem um menino nunca
faltou uma bergamota frutos de março
a descrição feita sempre por que nós
identificamos é que houve como
classificou como uma nova tendência
comum enfim econômico
esse investimento fez conclui altmann
este tipo de abordagem fez com que ele
não tenha ganho a melhor carta de vinhos
regional do mundo
nós não temos filmes mais caros nós
temos um dos mais icônicos nós temos
personalidade e excepcionalidade que nós
temos que desmistificar e descomplica lá
para que as pessoas possam efectivamente
escolher fim
isso é fantástico e posiciona portugal
no radar mundial de smith fica a quase
impossível escolha e para as pessoas que
insistem num eu não sei nada 30 por
criança extremamente nós não temos todos
que ser ex paris
o vinho tem tanta emoção como tem
deficiência e os consumidores é que
tenho o privilégio que só sentirá
anunciar os ex participantes têm que
entender e ciência e de vez em quando
sentem e mixa e os vinhos que navegavam
móvel aumentou 81 cariri são os vinhos
têm a capacidade de fintar o meu sensor
menores em fazer viajar para vinha de
ontem a origem são os tais vinhos
consciência faz o ginga os autênticos
que falava e cada um de nós tem o seu ea
maior parte não tem que discar
foram uma frutos formais nem receber do
tanino normal bergamota temos só que ver
aqui o estamos e esse é o gosto ou não
gosto muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah